the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
thank you so okay let's continue with
vectors and operations on them so
remember yesterday we saw the topic
yesterday was dot product and a member
of the definition of dot product
well the dot product of two vectors is
obtained by multiplying the first
component with the first component the
second with the second and so on and
summing these and you get a scalar and
the geometric interpretation of that is
that you can also take the length of a
take the length of B multiply them and
multiply that by the cosine of the angle
between the two vectors so we've seen
several applications of that so one
application is to find lengths and
angles
so for example where you can use this
relation to give you that the cosine of
the angle between two vectors is the dot
product divided by the product of the
lengths another application that we have
is to detect whether two vectors are
perpendicular so to decide if two
vectors are perpendicular to each other
all we have to do is compute the dot
product and see if we get zero okay and
well one third application that we don't
have time to discuss yesterday that I
will mention very quickly is to find
components of so let's say find the
component of a vector a along a
direction u so some unit vector so let
me explain let's say that I have some
direction for example the horizontal
axis from this blackboard but it could
be any direction in space and to
describe this direction maybe I have a
unit vector along this axis let's say
that I have any other vector a and I
want to find out what is the component
of a along U so that means what is the
length of this projection of a to the
given direction okay so this thing here
is the component
of a along you well how do we find that
well we know that here we have a right
angle so this component is just length a
times cosine of the angle between a and
u but now that means actually we can
compute it very easily because well I
could you know that's the same as length
a times length U times cosine theta
because U is a unit vector it's a unit
vector that means this is equal to one
and so that's the same as the dot
product between a and u ok so that's
very easy and of course the most obvious
cases of that is say for example we want
us to find the component along I hat the
first axis you know the unit vector
along the x axis then you do the dot
product with I hat which is 1 0 0 what
you get is the first component and
that's indeed the X component of the
vector similarly say you want the Z
component you do the dot product with K
that gives you the last component of
your vector but the same works with a
unit vector in any direction ok so
what's an application of that
well for example in physics maybe you
have seen situations where you have a
pendulum that swings so you have maybe
some mass at the end of the string and
that maths wings back and forth on the
circle and to analyze this mechanically
you want to use of course Newton's laws
of mechanics and you want to use well
you know forces and so on but I claim
that components of vectors are useful
here to understand what happens
geometrically so whatever force is
exerted on this pendulum
well there's its weight which usually
points downward and there's the tension
of the string and these two forces
together are what explains how this
pendulum is going to move back and forth
now you could try to understand the
equations of motion using XY coordinates
or maybe XZ or whatever you want to call
them 6a X Y but really what causes the
pendulum to swing back and forth and
also to somehow stay at constant
distance are phenomenal relative to this
circular trajectory so for example maybe
instead of taking components along the x
and y axes we want to look at two other
unit vectors so we can look at a vector
let's call it T that's tangent to the
trajectory
so I can you hate it if it's not very
readable so T is tangent to the
trajectory and on the other hand we can
introduce another vector let's call that
N and that one is normal or
perpendicular to the trajectory and so
now if you think about it you can look
at the components of the weight along
the tangent direction and along the
normal direction and so the component of
F along the tangent direction is what
causes acceleration in the direction
along the trajectory it's what causes
the pendulum to swing back and forth
and the component along n on the other
hand so that's the part of the weight
that tends to pull a mess away from this
point is what's going to be responsible
for the tension of the string it's why
the string is towed and not actually
slack and you know with things moving
all over the place so that one is
responsible for the tension of a string
and now of course if you want to compute
things well maybe you will call this
angle theta and when you will express
things explicitly using sines and
cosines and you will solve for the
equations of motion okay that would be a
very interesting physics problem but to
save time we're not going to do it I'm
sure you've seen that in 801 or similar
classes and so to find these components
we would just do dot products okay any
questions
No okay so let's move on to our next
topic so here we have found things about
length angles and stuff like that one
important concept that we haven't
understood yet in terms of vectors is
area so let's say that you know we want
to find the area of this Pentagon well
how do we compute that using vectors can
we do it using vectors yes we can and
that's going to be the goal but how so
the first thing we should do is probably
simplify the problem you know we don't
actually need to bother with Pentagon's
all we need to know our triangles
because for example you can cut that
into three triangles and then sum the
areas of the triangles okay so perhaps
easier what's the area of a triangle so
let's start with you know a triangle in
the plane and well then we need two
vectors to describe it say a and B here
how do we find the area of a triangle
well we all know base times height / -
so what's the base would be height well
so the area of this triangle is going to
be one-half of the base is going to be
the length of a and the height well if
you call theta this angle then this is
length B sine theta
now that looks a lot like the formula we
had there except for one little catch
this is a sign instead of a cosign how
do we deal with that well what we could
do is first find the cosine of the angle
we know how to find the cosine of the
angle using that product then solve for
sine using sine square plus cosine
square equals 1 and then plug that back
into here well that works but it's kind
of a very complicated way of doing it so
there's an easier way and that's going
to be determinant but let me explain how
we get to that maybe still doing
elementary geometry and dot products
first so let's see
what we can do is instead of finding the
sine of theta well we're not good at
finding signs of angles but we are very
good now at finding cosines of angles so
maybe we can find another angle whose
cosine is the same as the sine of theta
well you probably heard about
complementary angles and how you know if
I take my vector a let my vector B here
I have an angle theta well let's say
that I rotate my vector a by 90 degrees
to get a new vector a prime okay so a
prime is just a rotated by 90 degrees
then the angle between these two guys
let's say theta prime well beta prime is
90 degrees of PI over 2 radians minus
theta so in particular cosine of theta
prime is equal to sine of theta so in
particular that means that length a
length B sine theta which is what we
would need to know in order to find the
area of this triangle is equal to well a
and a prime have the same length so let
me replace that by length of a prime I'm
not changing anything length B cosine
theta prime and now we have something
that's much easier of course because
that's just a prime dot B okay so that
looks like a very good plan there's only
one small thing which is we don't know
yet how to find this a prime well I
claim it's not very hard let's see
why don't you guys do do the hablok so
let's say that I have a plane vector a
with two components a 1 a 2 and I want
to rotate it counterclockwise by 90
degrees so it looks like maybe we should
change some signs somewhere we should do
something with the components can you
come up with an idea of what it might be
okay so I see a lot of people answering
way I see some other answers but the
majority vote seems to be number three -
A two and A one I think I agree so let's
see let's say that we have this vector a
with components
a 1 so a 1 is here and a 2 so a 2 is
here ok let's rotate this box by 90
degrees counterclockwise so this
rectangular box ends up there it's the
same box just flipped on its side so
this length here becomes a 1 and this
length here becomes a 2 and that means
our new vector a prime is going to be
well the first component looks like an A
- but it's pointing to the left when a 2
is positive so it relates minus a 2 and
the y component is going to be the same
as this guy so it's going to be a 1 if
you wanted instead to rotate clockwise
then you would do the opposite you would
do a 2 minus a 1 okay is that reasonably
clear for everyone okay so well let's
continue a calculation where a prime
we've decided is minus a 2 from a 1 so
minus a 2 A 1 dot product with let's
call B 1 and B 2 the components of D
then that will be well minus a 2 B 1
plus a 1 B 2 let me write that the other
way around a 1 B 2 minus a 2 B 1 and
that's a quantity that you may already
know another name of determinants of
vectors a and B which we write
symbolically using this notation so we
put a and B next to each other inside a
2x2 table and we put these vertical bars
and that means the determinant of these
numbers it means this guy times this guy
- this guy
time-space guy so that's called the
determinant
and geometrically what it measures is
the area well not of a triangle because
we didn't divide by two but of a
parallelogram formed by a and B so it
measures it out here of the
parallelogram with sides a and B and of
course if you want with high angle then
you will just divide by two
if the triangle is half a parallelogram
there's one small catch the area usually
is something that's going to be positive
this guy here has no reason to be
positive or negative because in fact
well if you compute things you will see
that whether it's positive or negative
depends on whether a and B are clockwise
or counterclockwise from each other I
mean the issue that we have well when we
say the area is 1/2 length a length B
sine theta that was assuming that theta
is positive that it's sine is positive
otherwise if theta is negative maybe we
need to take the absolute value of this
so just to be not hopeful I will say the
determinant is either plus or minus the
area okay any questions about this
yes
oh sorry that's not a dot product that's
a usual multiplication okay that's a
length a times length B times sine theta
and so that's equal to the area of a
parallelogram so let me explain that
again so if I have two vectors a and B
so I can form a parallelogram with them
I can form a triangle okay and so the
area of the parallelogram is equal to
length a length B sine theta is equal to
the determinant of a and B while the
area of the triangle is one-half of that
and again to be truthful I should say
these things can be positive or negative
so depending on whether you count the
angle positively or negatively you will
get either the area of - the area the
area is actually the absolute value of
this quantities okay is that clear
okay
yes so if you want to compute the area
you will just take the absolute value of
the determinant okay so now I will be
well I should say the area of the
parallelogram so that it's completely
clear sorry you have a snow question
explain again so with the question how
the determinant equals the area of a
parallelogram okay so the area of a
parallelogram it's going to be the base
times the height right so the base let's
take this guy to be the base so the
length of a base will be length of a and
the height will be obtained by taking B
but only looking at the vertical part so
that will be length of B times the sine
of theta okay so that's how I got that
the area of a parallelogram is length a
length B sine theta and when I did this
manipulation and this track of rotating
to find a nice formula yes so you're
asking ahead of what I'm going to do in
a few minutes so you're asking about
many feet of a cross B so we're going to
learn about cross product in a few
minutes and the answer is yes but cross
product is for vectors in space here I
was simplifying things by doing things
just in the plane
okay so just bear with me for five more
minutes and we'll do things in space yes
that's correct the way you compute this
in practice is you just do this okay
that's how you compute the determinant
yes what about so for dimensions we are
going to do now okay
more questions should we move to okay
let's move to space
so so that's two things we can do in
space and you know you can find you can
look for the volume of solids or you can
look for the area of surfaces so let me
start with easy over to let me start
with volumes of solids and we'll go back
to area I promise
so I claim that there's also a notion of
determinants in space and that's going
to tell us how to find volumes so let's
say that we have three vectors a B and C
and then the definition of the
determinant is going to be so the
notation for that in terms of the
components is the same as above where we
put the components of a the components
of B and the components of C inside the
article bars okay and of course I have
to give a meaning to this so this will
be a number and what is that number well
the definition I will take is that this
is a1 times the determinant of what I
get by looking in this lower right
corner so the 2 by 2 determinant b2 b3
c2 c3 then I will subtract a 2 times the
determinant of b1 b3 c1 c3 and then I
will add a 3 times the determinant b1 b2
c1 c2 and each of these guys means again
you take b2 times c3 minus c2 times b3
and this times that minus this times
that and so on so in fact there's a
total of six terms in here
okay and maybe some of you have already
seen a different formula for theta 3
determinants where you directly have the
six terms it's the same it's the same
definition so how to remember the
structure of this formula well it's
called an this is called an expansion
according to the first hole so we're
going to take the entries in the first
hole a 1 a 2 a 3 and for each of them we
get a term namely we multiply it by a 2
by 2 determinant that we get by deleting
the first pole and the column where we
are okay so here the coefficient next to
a 1 is when we delete this column and
this row and we are left with B 2 B 3 C
2 C 3
next the next one we take a 2 we delete
the robots in it and the column that
it's in and we are left with B 1 B 3 C 1
C 3 and similarly with a 3 we take what
remains that's B 1 B 2 C 1 C 2
finally last but not least there's a
minus sign here for the second game ok
so well it looks like a weird formula
and I mean it is a little bit weird but
it's a formula that you should learn
because it's really really useful for a
lot of things so I should say if this
looks very artificial to you and you
like to know more there's more in the
notes so read the notes they will tell
you a bit more about what this means
where it comes from and so on if you
want to know a lot more then someday you
should take 1806 linear algebra where
you will learn a lot more about
determinants in n-dimensional space with
n vectors and there's a generalization
of this in arbitrary dimensions in this
class we'll only deal with two or three
dimensions yes
so why is
why is the negative there well that's a
very good question it has to be there so
that this will actually equal well what
I'm going to say right now is that this
will give us the volume of the box with
sides a B C and the formula just doesn't
work if you don't put the negative
there's a more fundamental reason which
has to do with orientation of space and
the fact that if you switch to
coordinates in space then basically you
change what's called the handedness of
the coordinates if you look at your
right hand and your left hand they are
not actually the same they're mirror
images and if you swap two coordinate
axes that's what you get that's the
fundamental reason for the - but again I
mean we don't need to think too much
about that all we need in this class is
the formula
so why do we care about this formula
it's because of a theorem that says that
geometrically the determinant of the
three vectors a B C is again plus or
minus this determinant could be positive
or negative seed as minuses and there's
all sorts of stuff plus or minus the
volume of the parallelepiped but just a
fancy name for a box with parallel
downsides in case you wonder with sides
a B and C okay so you take the five
actors a B and C and you form a box
whose sides are all parallelograms and
when it's volume is going to be the
determinant
okay that questions
oh I'm sorry I can't quite hear you
yes we are going to see how to do it
geometrically without a determinant but
then you'll see that you actually need a
determinant to compute it no matter what
so we are going to go back to this and
see another formula for volume but
you'll see that when I am cheating I
mean the important way and then somehow
computationally the only way to compute
it is ready to use a determinant yes
that's correct
in general I mean actually I should say
if you look at the 2 by 2 determinant
see you can also explain it in terms of
this expansion you take a 1 and multiply
by this 1 by 1 determinant b2 then you
take a 2 you multiply it by this 1 by 1
day time and b1 but you put a minus sign
and in general indeed when you expand
you would start putting plus minus plus
minus alternatingly more about that in
1806 yes there's a way to do it based on
other holes as well but then you have to
be very careful with the sign factors so
I will refer you to the notes for that
ok if you did it with I mean you could
also do it with a column by the way just
I mean be careful about the sign rules
so given how how little will use the
dominance in this class I mean will use
them in a way that's fundamental but we
won't compute much so let's say this is
going to be enough force for now ok so
after determinants now I can tell you
about cross product and cross product is
going to be the answer to your question
about Aria
okay so okay so let me move on to cross
product so post product is something
that you can apply to two vectors in
space and they gotta mean whether in
three-dimensional space okay
this is something that's specific to
three dimensions so the definition a
plus B so it's important to really do
your multiplication symbol well so that
you don't mistake it with a dot product
well that's going to be a vector okay so
that's another reason not to confuse it
with dot product dot product gives you a
number cross product gives you a vector
so they are very completely different
operations they are both called product
because well somehow one couldn't come
up with a better name but they are
completely different operations okay so
what do we do to do the cross product of
a and B well we do something very
strange
just after I've told you that a
determinant is something where we put
numbers and we get a number I'm going to
violate my own rule I'm going to put
together a determinant in which well the
last two holes are the components of the
vectors a and B with the first or
strangely consists of the unit vectors
ijk what does that mean well that
certainly is not a determinant in the
usual sense you cannot you know if you
try to put that into your calculator it
will tell you there's an error I don't
know how to put vectors in there I want
numbers what it means is it's a symbolic
notation that helps you remember what
the formula is so the actual formula is
well you use this definition and you
know if you use this definition you see
that it's I hat times sum
well ok so let me write it as
determinant of a2 a3 b2 b3 times I hat
minus determinant a1 a3 b1 b3 J hat plus
a1 a2 b1 b2 k hat okay and so that's the
actual definition in a way that makes
complete sense but to remember this
formula without too much trouble it's
much easier to think of it to think
about it in these terms here ok so
that's a definition and it gives you a
vector now as usual with definitions the
question is what is it good for what is
the geometric meaning of this very
strange relation why do we bother to do
that
so here's what it does geometrically so
remember a vector has two different
things it has a length and it has a
direction okay let's start with the
length the length of the cross product
is the area of the parallelogram in
space formed by the vectors a and B okay
so now if you have a diagram in space
you can find our higher just by doing
this calculation when you go to
coordinates of the point you do this
calculation and then you take the length
so the length you know you take this
squared plus red square plus red squared
square root it looks like a very
complicated formula but it works and
actually it's the simplest way to do it
okay this time we don't actually need to
put plus or minus because the length of
a vector is always positive we don't
have to worry about that and what's even
more magical is that not only is the
length remarkable but the direction is
also remarkable so the direction of a
cross B is perpendicular to the plane of
a parallelogram
so you know our two vectors a and B
together of a determiner plane and what
I'm telling you is that the vector a
cross B will Point will stick straight
out of that plane perpendicular to it so
in fact I have to be more precise
there's two ways that you can be
perpendicular perpendicular to this
plane right you can be perpendicular
pointing up or pointing down how do I
decide which well that's something
called the right hand rule okay so what
does the right hand will say well
there's various versions right hand of
all depending in which country you learn
about it in France given the culture you
even learn about it in terms of a [ __ ]
crow and a wine bottle but I think and I
just use the usual version here so you
take your right hand if you're
left-handed remember to take your right
hand not the left one the other the
other right okay and then place your
hand to point in the direction of a so
let's say my right hand is going in that
direction now curl your fingers so that
they point towards B so here that would
be kind of into the blackboard okay
don't snap any bones if it doesn't quite
work then rotate your arms so that you
can actually physically do it then you
know get your thumb to stick straight
out well here my thumb is going to go up
and that tells me that a cos B will go
up okay so let me write that down while
you experiment with it
again try not to enjoy yourselves so
first your right hand points parallel to
vector a then fingers point in the
direction of B then your thumb when you
stick it out is going to point in the
direction of a cross B okay let's do a
quick example
let's make quick example here let's take
i cross-checked
so
I see some of you well most of you are
going in the right direction if you have
it pointing in the wrong direction it
might mean that you're using your left
hand for example okay so example I claim
that I cross J equals K okay let's see I
point to others J points to our height
so I guess this is your height height I
think it's kind of hard to and then your
thumb is going to point up okay so that
tells us it's roughly pointing up and of
course the length should be one because
if you take the unit square in the XY
plane is area is one and the direction
should indeed be vertical because it
should be perpendicular to the XY plane
so looks like I cross J will be K well
let's check with a definition
you know ijk what is I I is 1 0 0 J is 0
1 0 well so the coefficient of I will be
0 times 0 minus 0 times 1 that's 0
coefficient of J will be 1 times 0 minus
0 times 0 that's 0 minus 0 J doesn't
matter a bit and the coefficient of K
will be 1 times 1 that's 1 minus 0 times
0 1 K ok
so we do get I plus J equals K both ways
in this case it's easier to do
geometrically if I give you more
complicated vectors probably you will
actually want to do the calculation okay
any questions yes
so the coefficient of K remember I take
so I delete the first row and the last
column so I get this two-by-two
determinant
again that two-by-two determinant is 1
times 1 minus 0 times 0 so that gives me
1 ok
that's what you do with 2 by 2
determinants similarly for viewers would
be others turn out to be 0 mark
questions yes let me repeat how I got
the 1 in front of K so remember the
definition of a determinant I expand
according to the entries in the first
hole when I get to K what I do is I
delete the first oh and I delete the
last column the column that contains K
okay so I delete these guys and these
guys I'm left with this two-by-two
determinant
now a 2 by 2 determinant you multiply
according to this downward diagonal and
then minus this times that okay so 1
times 1 let me say here I got 1 K
because that's 1 times 1 minus 0 times 0
equals 1 so and that's really hard to
read and it will be easier that way
okay yes
okay so let's try if I do the same for I
I think I will also get zero okay so
let's do the same for I so I think I I
delete the first row I delete the first
column I get this two-by-two determinant
here and I get 0 times 0 that's 0 minus
0 times 1 that's here the trick question
0 times 1 is 0 as well so that's 0 minus
0 is 0 ok so I hope in Monday you should
get more practice in recitation about
how to compute determinants so hopefully
it will become very easy for you all to
compute these things I know the first
time it's kind of a shock because
there's a lot of numbers and a lot of
things to do
see not good
okay
so okay so let me return to the question
that you asked a bit earlier about how
do I find actually volume if I don't
want to know about determinants well so
let's have another look I'd prefer you
okay so let's say that I have three
vectors let me put them this way a B and
C and let's try to see how else I could
think about the volume of this box okay
so probably you know that the volume of
a parallelepiped is the area of a base
times the height okay so sorry the
volume is the area of the base times the
height how do we do that in practice
well what's the area of a base so the
base is a parallelogram in space with
sides B and C how do we find the area of
a parallelogram in space well we just
discovered that we can do it by taking
the cross product so the area of the
base well we take the cross product of B
and C that's not quite it because this
is a vector we would like a number where
we take its length okay that's pretty
good what about the height well the
height is going to be the component of a
in the direction that's perpendicular to
the base so let's take a direction
that's perpendicular to the base let's
call that n a unit vector in that
direction then we can get the height by
taking a dot n that's what we saw at the
beginning of class that a dot n will
tell me how much a goes in the direction
of N
are you still with me okay let's keep
going
so let's think about this vector and how
do I get it
well I can get it by actually using
cross product as well because I said the
direction perpendicular of the two
vectors I can get by taking the cross
product and looking at that direction so
this is still because c.length
and this one is so I claim I should do
an aside here and can be obtained by
taking B cross C well that points in the
right direction but it's not a unit
vector how do I get a unit vector I
divide by the length thanks so I take B
cross C they divide by length because C
well now I can probably simplify between
these two guys
and so what I will get
oops
to be the last thing today what I get
out of this is that my volume equals a
dot product with the vector B cross C
and of course I have to be careful in
which other I do it if I do it the other
way around a dot B I get a number I
cannot close that so I mean I really
have to do the cross-product first I get
a new vector then i dot product okay so
the fact is that the determinant of ABC
is equal to this so-called triple
product well that looks good
geometrically let's try to check whether
it makes sense with the formulas just
one small thing so we solve the
determinant is a one times determinant
it will be free si tu savais minus a2
times something plus a freight and
something I let you fill in the numbers
okay that's this guy what about this guy
well dot product we take the first
component of a that's a 1 we multiplied
by the first component of B cross C
what's the first column of B cross C
well is this determinant b2 b3 c2 c3
right if you look at if you put B and C
instead of a and B into there you'll get
a 2 I component is this guy - well plus
a 2 times the second component which is
minus some determinant plus a 3 times
the third component which is again a
determinant and you can check to get
exactly the same expression so
everything is fine there's no
contradiction in math just yet ok
so well on Tuesday we'll continue with
this and we'll start going into matrices
equations of planes and so on meanwhile
have a good weekend and please stop
working on your problem sets so that you
can ask lots of questions to your TAS on
Monday